This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. If you tried to buy toilet paper in the last few weeks, I suspect you might have found yourself staring at an empty aisle in the grocery store. One drain where all the toilet paper has gone. The first thought that came to my mind was that miserable hoarders took it all.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。如果你在过去几周尝试购买卫生纸，我猜你可能发现自己正盯着杂货店空荡荡的货架发呆。卫生纸仿佛被什么东西吸干了一样。我脑海中闪过的第一个念头是，那些可恶的囤积者把它们全买光了。
And then I started contemplating the volume of a package of toilet paper, especially those massive, you know, like the equivalent of 96 rolls packs that you see at Target, and I thought, if just a couple dozen people bought one extra package, that would clean out an entire shelf. And buying one extra package is not that unreasonable
然后我开始思考一包卫生纸的体积，尤其是你在塔吉特百货看到的那种巨大的、相当于96卷装的包装。我想，如果只要几十个人多买一包，就能把整个货架清空。而多买一包其实并不算太离谱，
if your whole family is trapped in the house and not using the toilet at work or at school or out in the world. And this run of toilet paper is not limited to the United States. And I'll show you a man wrote this valid in the world. And this run of toilet paper is not limited to the United States. And Australian man wrote this valid about the toilet paper shortage. Now we've faced wars and cyclones,
如果你的全家人都被困在家里，不能在工作、学校或外面使用厕所的话。这种卫生纸抢购潮不仅限于美国。我给你们看一位男士写的关于卫生纸短缺的顺口溜。我们经历过战争和飓风，
we've survived the war as one. But a toilet paper shortage, what made us come undone. For the people started hoarding all the last remaining sheets. There were punch-shones in the aisles, there was panic in the streets. Me cracks in need of weapons, someone cried in desperation.
我们曾共同挺过战争。但卫生纸短缺，却让我们乱了阵脚。人们开始囤积最后剩下的纸张。过道里出现了拳头，街头陷入恐慌。有人绝望地哭喊着需要武器。
What else can I bloody use to solve this situation? And in the Netherlands, a Dutch worker went viral after he filmed a video of himself zooming around a warehouse stacked to the rafters with toilet paper, laughing maniacally. and over toilet paper. I can confirm that firsthand. This is not an IPI contributor, Stephanie Joyce. So Stephanie, what have you seen firsthand? Yeah, so a month ago, when people really started going crazy over toilet paper,
我还能用什么该死的东西来解决这个问题？在荷兰，一位荷兰工人在拍摄了一段自己在堆满卫生纸的仓库里飞驰、疯狂大笑的视频后走红了。关于卫生纸，我可以亲身证实这一点。这是《99%隐形》的撰稿人斯蒂芬妮·乔伊斯。那么斯蒂芬妮，你亲眼看到了什么？是的，一个月前，当人们真的开始为卫生纸疯狂时，
I actually heard about a company here in New Mexico where I live that makes toilet paper. It's called Rose's Southwest. Now, for obvious reasons, this is not a company that I had heard of before the coronavirus. But when stories started, you know, coming out about people running out of toilet paper, Rose's announced that it was going to start doing public sales of toilet paper from its warehouse in Albuquerque. For those of you struggling to find toilet paper, we found a place here in Albuquerque with lots of it.
我听说在新墨西哥州我住的地方有一家生产卫生纸的公司。它叫“玫瑰西南”。出于显而易见的原因，在新冠疫情之前我没听说过这家公司。但当人们开始因为用光卫生纸而恐慌的故事传出来时，玫瑰公司宣布将开始在其阿尔伯克基的仓库向公众直接销售卫生纸。对于那些难以买到卫生纸的人，我们在阿尔伯克基找到了一个有很多存货的地方。
It's cash only, 35 bucks for 96 rolls. So they're just starting it. So what do they normally do? Yeah, so roses doesn't usually sell directly to the public. There's this funny division in the toilet paper world between the at-home and the away from home markets. And roses isn't a way from home wholesaler. So when you're out in the world at a restaurant or at a sports stadium or a convenience store, they sell toilet paper to those
只收现金，35美元96卷。他们才刚刚开始。那么他们平时做什么呢？是的，玫瑰公司通常不直接向公众销售。卫生纸行业有一个有趣的划分，分为家庭用和非家庭用市场。玫瑰公司是一家非家庭用批发商。所以当你身处餐厅、体育场或便利店时，他们会向这些
businesses. But as you said, of course, now fewer people are out in the world using those businesses. Instead, everyone is trying to stock up their paper at home where they're spending all of their time. And that's part of the reason why it's flying off the shelves. And so in an attempt to help people who are trying to get toilet paper, Roses has decided to sell directly to the public at a kiosk right outside their factory. And I was curious who's gonna show up to these sales? So I decided to go down to their next public sale. It was on a Friday morning, a few weeks back.
企业销售卫生纸。但正如你所说，当然，现在很少有人在外面使用这些设施。相反，每个人都试图在家里囤积纸张，因为他们把所有时间都花在家里。这就是它被抢购一空的部分原因。为了帮助那些试图买到卫生纸的人，玫瑰公司决定在工厂外的一个亭子里直接向公众销售。我很好奇谁会来买？所以我决定去看看他们的下一次公开销售。那是几周前的一个周五早上。
I should say before New Mexico asked people to stay at home. I woke up super, super early, and I headed down to Albuquerque to check it out. And let me tell you, I was not prepared for this scene. This is a tape of me when I arrived. It is insane. There are cars literally as far as I can see in any direction waiting in line to purchase toilet paper.
我应该说是在新墨西哥州要求人们居家隔离之前。我起得非常非常早，前往阿尔伯克基一探究竟。我得告诉你，我完全没准备好面对那样的场景。这是我到达时录下的音频。太疯狂了。我能看到的任何方向，车队都排得一眼望不到头，等着买卫生纸。
Wait, so there are like multiple lines of cars filled with people all waiting to buy toilet paper from this one key ask. Yes, coming from literally every direction. I found out later that the longest line was almost three miles long. Three miles. Yes, which is crazy.
等等，所以有几排车队，里面全是等着从这一个亭子买卫生纸的人？是的，从四面八方涌来。我后来发现，最长的队伍几乎有三英里长。三英里。是的，这太疯狂了。
So of course, I started to interview people who are waiting in their cars in line. And just a warning, the audio quality isn't super great. I was using this really long poll to hold the microphone so I could stay at least six feet away from people. And I was also talking to people through their rolled down passenger side windows for the most part.
所以当然，我开始采访那些在车里排队的人。先提醒一下，音频质量不是特别好。我用了一根很长的杆子来固定麦克风，这样我至少能和人们保持六英尺的距离。而且大部分时间我都是隔着他们摇下的副驾驶车窗和他们交谈。
So it's not the best audio quality. But one of the first people I talked to was this woman named Brittany Perea. She was there with her three-year-old daughter, Azul Saina. How long have you been in line today? Um, so seven. Wow. Yes. Seven.
所以音频质量不是最好的。但我采访的第一批人之一是一位名叫布列塔尼·佩雷亚的女士。她带着三岁的女儿阿祖尔·赛娜在那里。你今天排了多久了？嗯，七点。哇。是的。七点。
Yeah, well, she needed the bathroom, so I had to go take her to the bathroom and I lost my place in line. That's not again. Oh my God. What's your plan if I had to go take her to the bathroom and I lost my place in line. That's not again. Oh my God. What's your plan if she has to go to bathroom again? We did. We had to. I just opened the door and she used it on the side. I told her I was a home to like you're sitting and just pee.
是的，她需要上厕所，所以我不得不带她去上厕所，结果我排队的位置丢了。这太糟糕了。天哪。如果她又要上厕所，你打算怎么办？我们做到了。我们不得不这样做。我只是打开车门，让她在路边解决了。我告诉她，我就像在家里一样，你坐着尿就行。
I told her. Really? Yeah. What way did it on the side of here? Oh my Lord. She had her daughter pee out the door of the car while waiting for toilet paper. There's so many levels of irony to that. I know. And just horror. Yeah. Oh my god.
我告诉她。真的吗？是的。她在路边解决了？天哪。她让女儿在等卫生纸的时候在车门边小便。这其中有太多的讽刺意味了。我知道。简直太可怕了。
Yeah. Yeah. And Brittany realized how insane all of this was. She told me that like when she had seen the line earlier in the week when she was running errands, she had laughed at the people who were lined up. She thought they were totally ridiculous. But then she actually started running low on toilet paper and she went to half a dozen grocery stores and they were all completely out. I saw this line last week on Friday and I was like, these people are ridiculous. But I'm down to like two rows. Yeah, I need to have a favorite. If I had like five or six, I wouldn't bother, but I'm down to like two rows. Yeah, I need to have a favorite. If I had like five or six, I wouldn't bother, but yeah, I'm on my last two rows. So yeah, but it doesn't make no sense
是的。是的。布列塔尼意识到这一切有多疯狂。她告诉我，当她本周早些时候在办杂事看到这条队伍时，她还嘲笑过排队的人。她觉得他们太荒谬了。但后来她自己的卫生纸真的快用完了，她去了半打杂货店，结果全都卖光了。我上周五看到这条队伍时，心想，这些人真是荒谬。但我只剩下两卷了。是的，我需要一些。如果我有五六卷，我就不会费这个劲了，但我只剩下最后两卷了。所以，这对我来说一点意义都没有。
to me. So she's not like a hoarder or anything trying to get a year supply of toilet paper. So she's fine or even to sell toilet paper or anything like she's legitimately out and she was one of those people actually like me who was like, this is a non-perishable supply. She's the non-perishable product. Why is anyone having to stock up on it, but then she's just caught and find that she just doesn't have any. Yeah, exactly.
所以她不是那种试图囤积一年卫生纸的囤积者。她甚至不是为了转卖，她是真的用完了。她和当初的我一样，觉得这是一种非易腐品。她觉得这是一种非易腐产品，为什么有人需要囤积它？但后来她发现自己真的没有了。是的，完全正确。
And that's what I heard from people over and over again as I walked down the line. Never in the lifetime would I thought I'd be waiting to like for Toyota paper. I could see waiting for food, a box of food, but. Okay, Roman, one last person for you. This is a woman named Mary Salas Cedillo and she was there with her granddaughters,
这就是我沿着队伍走时一遍又一遍听到的。我这辈子都没想过我会为了卫生纸排队。我可以理解为了食物排队，为了领一箱食物，但是……好了，罗曼，最后一个人。这是一位名叫玛丽·萨拉斯·塞迪略的女士，她和孙女们在一起，
Felia and Amor. She told me that they woke up at 4 a.m. to get in line, which meant that by the time I talked to them, they'd argue in line for almost five hours. Oh my God. And it's not like they just woke up and got in line. No, they strategized. They didn't have anything to eat or drink all morning
费利亚和阿莫尔。她告诉我，她们凌晨4点就起床来排队，这意味着我采访她们时，她们已经排了近五个小时了。天哪。而且她们不是起床就直接来排队的。不，她们有策略。她们整个早上什么都没吃没喝，
so they wouldn't have to go to the bathroom. Yeah, I told the girls I'll buy you something to eat afterward. Are you hungry? Not really. Not really. I am. She is. When I was a kid, I used to beg my mom to take me with her on errands, but that's got to be the worst errand of all time. But what's clear is that people are willing to go to extreme lengths to avoid running out of toilet paper. Yeah, I mean, obviously you get the point. But I find this super fascinating. I mean, toilet paper, it's like, I guess important,
这样就不用去上厕所了。是的，我告诉孩子们，之后我会给你们买吃的。你们饿吗？不太饿。不太饿。我饿了。她是。我小时候常求妈妈带我一起去办杂事，但这绝对是有史以来最糟糕的差事。但显而易见的是，人们愿意为了不让卫生纸用完而采取极端手段。是的，我的意思是，显然你明白了。但我发现这非常迷人。我的意思是，卫生纸，我想它很重要，
but it's also not perishable. It's not food or water. So like, why were these people desperate for toilet paper? So this is a good question, and the more the reasons why we wanted to talk to you. Because I want to know actually, how we became so reliant on this one product. Right, and so I decided to actually look into the
但它也不是易腐品。它不是食物或水。所以，为什么这些人对卫生纸如此绝望？这是一个好问题，也是我们想和你谈谈的原因之一。因为我想知道，我们究竟是如何变得如此依赖这一种产品的。没错，所以我决定深入研究一下
history a little bit and fundamentally I think this is a story about the genius of marketing. Because obviously for most of history people would have thought it was insane to manufacture something specifically for the purpose of cleaning yourself. Basically, people would use whatever an open intended at hand, including their own hands. So this is Ron Bloomer. And Bloomer wrote a book called Wiped. It's a history of Riren Hygiene. And he says that for most of human existence you know people didn't have anything like paper they used rocks they used shells they used moss or you know they use the original cleaner water the idea is you you wet your hand
历史。从根本上说，我认为这是一个关于营销天才的故事。因为显然在历史上大部分时间里，人们会觉得专门制造一种用来清洁自己的东西是疯了。基本上，人们会使用手边任何方便的东西，包括他们自己的手。这是罗恩·布卢默。布卢默写了一本名为《擦拭》的书。这是一部关于后部卫生的历史。他说，在人类存在的大部分时间里，人们没有任何像纸一样的东西，他们用石头、贝壳、苔藓，或者你知道的，他们使用最初的清洁剂——水。这个想法是，你用
with water and you use your your left hand to clean your rear end and then you wash your hand and then you rinse and repeat, as they say. I mean, this makes sense, there's some cultures, like where your left hand is used for ablutions, for cleaning, and that's just part of the ritual, and then your right hand is for eating and greeting people. So water makes a ton of sense to me, shells on the other hand,
水弄湿你的手，用左手清洁你的后部，然后洗手，然后再冲洗，就像他们说的那样。我的意思是，这很有道理，有些文化中，左手是用来洗涤、清洁的，这只是仪式的一部分，而右手是用来吃饭和问候人的。所以水对我来说很有意义，而贝壳，另一方面，
do not make that much sense. Yeah, I didn't get into too much detail with Ron about how exactly that would work. The historical method that I personally found myself questioning that he described was the Romans. They had a sponge on a stick, which was sitting in a pale of water in these communal bathrooms. And they would use it to clean their rear ends and then they'd put it back in the bucket. And then the next person would swish it around, hopefully,
就没那么有意义了。是的，我没有和罗恩详细讨论这到底是怎么运作的。他描述的那个我个人质疑的历史方法是罗马人。他们在公共厕所里有一个放在水桶里的海绵棍。他们会用它来清洁后部，然后把它放回桶里。然后下一个人会把它搅一搅，希望如此，
pick it up and then clean their rear end. Oh my God, that's horrifying. I actually can't think about it for too long. It's just like, I'm telling myself they didn't know what we know about germs. They didn't know. Yeah, totally. Yeah. So there's all these methods that I think sound a little wild to us today, but there actually is one part of the world where disposable toilet paper has been used for a really long time. And that's China. China is,
拿起来，然后清洁他们的后部。天哪，那太可怕了。我真的不能想太久。我只是告诉自己，他们不知道我们现在所知道的关于细菌的知识。他们不知道。是的，完全正确。所以所有这些方法在我们今天看来都有点疯狂，但实际上世界上有一个地方很早就开始使用一次性卫生纸了。那就是中国。中国，
of course, where paper was invented. And starting in 500 or so, there are records of paper being used for wiping. And then starting in the 1300s, there are actually records of paper being made specifically for use in the toilet. So when does the idea of using paper catch on in the rest of the world in the West? So in the 16 and 1700s, paper is starting to become pretty widespread. The first newspapers get printed, you know, paper that's explicitly meant to be thrown out. And then in the late 1700s, we actually figured out how to make paper out of wood. It was made out of rags before.
当然，是造纸术的发明地。从公元500年左右开始，就有关于使用纸张进行擦拭的记录。从1300年代开始，甚至有专门为厕所使用而制造的纸张记录。那么，在世界其他地方，在西方，使用纸张的想法是什么时候流行起来的呢？在16和17世纪，纸张开始变得相当普遍。第一批报纸被印刷出来，你知道，专门为了被扔掉而设计的纸张。然后在18世纪末，我们实际上弄清楚了如何用木头造纸。之前它是用碎布做的。
And suddenly paper gets a whole lot cheaper. And most people are still using whatever is on hand. But it also does become common for people to start using paper. Now, this isn't paper that's specifically made for bum wiping. It takes a few more decades before anyone was actually making paper that was intended
突然间，纸张变得便宜多了。大多数人仍然使用手边任何东西。但人们开始使用纸张也变得普遍起来。现在，这并不是专门为擦屁股而制造的纸。又过了几十年，才有人真正开始制造专门用于
for that particular purpose. That was in the 1850s. And Bloomer credits a guy named Joseph Gaity with selling the first actual toilet paper in the Western world. And Gaity's sales pitch was basically using newspaper was bad for you. And so he decided to make this form of paper, which was thin and as he sold it more gentle on your delicate membranes and helping if you had hemorrhoids. So this toilet paper, would we recognize it as the toilet paper we have today? I don't think so.
那个特定目的的纸。那是在1850年代。布卢默将第一款真正的西方卫生纸的销售归功于一个叫约瑟夫·盖蒂的人。盖蒂的推销话术基本上是说使用报纸对你有害。所以他决定制造这种纸，它很薄，正如他所推销的那样，对你娇嫩的部位更温和，如果你有痔疮的话会有帮助。那么这种卫生纸，我们会认出它是我们今天用的卫生纸吗？我不这么认为。
No. It came in a box like tissues and it was made of hemp. And Blumer actually told me he got his hands on an original box of it. And it feels a bit like what we would call tissue paper. I don't think we would be very happy using it, but it was thin and I guess it would sort of do the job. So this was not a hugely popular product.
不。它装在一个像纸巾一样的盒子里，是用大麻做的。布卢默实际上告诉我，他弄到了一盒原始产品。它摸起来有点像我们所说的薄纸。我不认为我们会很乐意使用它，但它很薄，我想它大概能完成任务。所以这不是一个非常受欢迎的产品。
It cost a lot of money, so only rich people could afford it. And like most people really just didn't see the need when there was so much free paper out there. The Sears and Robot catalog cost absolutely nothing. It came in the mail. The whole toilet paper thing just didn't seem necessary to most people. And it might not have taken off.
它很贵，所以只有富人买得起。而且大多数人真的觉得没必要，因为外面有那么多免费的纸。西尔斯和罗巴克目录完全免费。它是通过邮件寄来的。整个卫生纸的事情对大多数人来说似乎并不必要。而且它可能不会流行起来，
If not for the fact that around the same time, there's another big change that happens in the human waste disposal world, and that changes indoor plumbing. So now people, you know, not only have toilets inside their houses, but they are, you know, those toilets are connected to pipes and sewer systems
如果不是因为大约在同一时间，人类废物处理领域发生了另一个重大变化，那就是室内管道。所以现在人们，你知道，不仅家里有厕所，而且这些厕所连接着管道和下水道系统，
as a way of disposing of the waste. Exactly, yeah. But as anyone who has spent time plunging a toilet before can tell you, you can't just be flushing newspaper down a toilet. You need something that's more delicate than that. Oh, like Gidey's paper, that's all. So for tourists, yeah.
作为处理废物的一种方式。没错，是的。但正如任何曾经用皮搋子疏通厕所的人所能告诉你的那样，你不能只是把报纸冲进厕所。你需要比那更精细的东西。哦，像盖蒂的纸，就是这样。所以对于游客来说，是的。
Exactly. So Gidey actually pivots, and he starts marketing his paper differently as good for use with indoor toilets and other people start to get in on the business. And among the early adopters is this guy from Albany, New York named Seth Wheeler and Wheeler is really the guy who creates toilet paper as you and I know it. Wheeler came up with the idea and packed into the idea of having a role that was perforated so that you could rip off a sheet at a time.
没错。所以盖蒂实际上转变了方向，他开始以不同的方式推销他的纸，称其适合室内厕所使用，其他人也开始加入这个行业。早期的采用者之一是来自纽约州奥尔巴尼的塞思·惠勒，惠勒确实是创造了你我所知的卫生纸的人。惠勒想出了这个主意，并申请了专利，即拥有一个有穿孔的卷筒，这样你就可以一次撕下一张。
And also he had to invent all the mechanisms, the roller, to hold it because people wouldn't have it. So he would sell the unit as a whole. So this guy is responsible for not only putting toilet paper on a roll, but actually dividing it into sheets. It really is the toilet paper as we know it. Yeah, and he's really, he's a toilet paper inventor.
而且他还必须发明所有的机制，即用来支撑它的滚筒，因为人们不会有它。所以他会把整个装置作为一个整体出售。所以这个人不仅负责把卫生纸卷起来，还负责把它分成一张一张的。这确实是我们所知的卫生纸。是的，他真的是一位卫生纸发明家。
In years after, he pens all these other ideas related to toilet paper. Some of them I would say more practical than others. He has the patent on hexagonal toilet paper, which he thought would be easier to tear from the roll. He has a patent on half a dozen different kinds of paper holder designs. Basically, he spent the rest of his life thinking about how to improve toilet paper.
在随后的几年里，他申请了所有这些与卫生纸相关的其他想法。其中一些我认为比其他的更实用。他拥有六角形卫生纸的专利，他认为这样更容易从卷筒上撕下来。他拥有半打不同种类的纸架设计的专利。基本上，他余生都在思考如何改进卫生纸。
I love people like that. I love people who are obsessed with these things. I mean, I don't know if he's a pleasure to be around as a person But I'm glad those people exist in the world. Yeah, I can't imagine what his dinner conversation would have been like but He was definitely a super successful inventor And he was a fine business man, you know his company sold a lot of toilet paper But he is not the person who actually makes toilet paper really an American essential. That is one of his competitors at the time, the Scott paper company. And this is the same Scott paper company that sells toilet paper today that you see.
我喜欢这样的人。我喜欢那些对这些事情着迷的人。我的意思是，我不知道他作为一个人在身边是否令人愉快，但我很高兴世界上有这样的人。是的，我无法想象他的晚餐谈话会是什么样子，但他绝对是一位非常成功的发明家。他是一位精明的商人，你知道他的公司卖了很多卫生纸。但他并不是真正让卫生纸成为美国必需品的人。那是他当时的一位竞争对手，斯科特纸业公司。这就是今天你看到的卖卫生纸的同一家斯科特纸业公司。
Like you used to see in the toilet paper aisle. Like you used to see in the toilet paper aisle, the very same, yes. And the Scott company starts making toilet paper right around you used to see in the toilet paper aisle, the very same, yes. And the Scott company starts making toilet paper right around the same time as Wheeler, but they are much better at marketing. They take that original idea that toilet paper is a solution to hemorrhids, and they really run with that. And you would see these horrifying ads and newspapers and magazines of doctors with scary-looking surgical instruments. And the doctor was saying to the other doctor, well, we wouldn't have to operate on this man if his wife had bought Scott toilet paper.
就像你过去在卫生纸货架上看到的那样。就像你过去在卫生纸货架上看到的那样，完全一样，是的。斯科特公司开始生产卫生纸的时间大约和你过去在卫生纸货架上看到的一样，但他们更擅长营销。他们采用了最初的想法，即卫生纸是痔疮的解决方案，并真正将其发扬光大。你会看到报纸和杂志上那些可怕的广告，医生拿着看起来很吓人的手术器械。医生对另一位医生说，好吧，如果他的妻子买了斯科特卫生纸，我们就不用给这个人做手术了。
And they would also attack their rivals by saying, well, so and so has wood chips or splinters in their toilet paper, you wouldn't want to use that, would you? It was nothing like fear to sell your product. Totally, yeah. But they also sold it as this sophisticated luxury item. That was their two pronged approach. So, there's this one ad that's in Bloomer's book that describes women of intuitive daintiness buying Scott tissue.
他们还会攻击竞争对手，说，某某人的卫生纸里有木屑或碎片，你不会想用那个的，对吧？没有什么比恐惧更能推销你的产品了。完全正确，是的。但他们也把它作为一种精致的奢侈品来销售。这就是他们的双管齐下策略。所以，布卢默书里有一则广告，描述了具有直觉优雅的女性购买斯科特纸巾。
Intuitive daintiness. Oh, I love it. It's so terrible. It's so terrible. Yeah. And it worked. They basically end up owning the market through the 1950s. And they make toilet paper.
直觉优雅。哦，我喜欢它。太糟糕了。太糟糕了。是的。而且它奏效了。他们基本上在1950年代之前就拥有了市场。他们制造了卫生纸。
This essential household product for most Americans. So for like less than 50 years, toilet paper goes from non-existent in the Western world to totally indispensable because of the Scott Paper Company. Yes. So indispensable that people are willing to wait five hours in line for it. I mean, toilet paper now is a $30 billion industry. We use, as Americans, I look this up, we use 28 pounds of toilet paper a year per person, which is 141 rolls.
这种对大多数美国人来说必不可少的家庭产品。所以不到50年，卫生纸从在西方世界不存在变成了完全不可或缺，这都要归功于斯科特纸业公司。是的。不可或缺到人们愿意排队五个小时去买它。我的意思是，卫生纸现在是一个300亿美元的产业。我们美国人，我查过了，每人每年使用28磅卫生纸，也就是141卷。
So many trees. So how are toilet paper manufacturers keeping up during this time of increased demand? I mean, I wanted to know that too. So when I was down in Albuquerque, I actually set up a meeting with the sales and marketing manager for Rose's Southwest. A guy named Gibson Orcher. Good time to be in the bathroom business for sure. Bath tissue.
这么多树。那么在需求增加的这段时间里，卫生纸制造商是如何跟上的呢？我的意思是，我也想知道这一点。所以当我在阿尔伯克基时，我实际上安排了与玫瑰西南公司销售和营销经理的会面。一个叫吉布森·奥彻的人。确实是进入厕所行业的好时机。沐浴纸。
That's right. That's the sexy term for it, right? Bath tissue. That's so much better than toilet paper. Okay, maybe not, but yeah, we do refer to it in the industry as a bath tissue. So is there actually a short supply of bath tissue then? I mean, yes and no, right?
没错。那是性感的术语，对吧？沐浴纸。这比卫生纸好听多了。好吧，也许不是，但是的，我们在行业内确实称之为沐浴纸。那么沐浴纸真的短缺吗？我的意思是，是也不是，对吧？
Yes, there is a shortage if you're trying to buy it at the grocery store. But if you take a step back and look at the entire toilet paper supply chain, the answer is no. Only a lot of other things that are kind of hard to find at the moment, the toilet paper supply chain is actually almost entirely here in the US, or at least here in North America. And so even though the coronavirus has disrupted a lot of things, it actually hasn't disrupted the toilet paper supply chain.
是的，如果你试图在杂货店买它，确实短缺。但如果你退后一步，看看整个卫生纸供应链，答案是否定的。除了目前很难找到的其他很多东西外，卫生纸供应链实际上几乎完全在美国，或者至少在北美。所以尽管新冠疫情扰乱了很多事情，但它实际上并没有扰乱卫生纸供应链。
You know, the trees are still getting cut down, paper mills are still running. You know, roses has actually added an extra shift to increase production and try and keep up with the demand. But keep in mind, Roman, it's not like people are actually consuming toilet paper any faster than usual. They are consuming it differently. So people are using more toilet paper at home, as opposed to at work or at restaurants. But that's not more toilet paper overall. That's just a breakdown in where the toilet paper is going.
你知道，树木仍在被砍伐，造纸厂仍在运转。你知道，玫瑰公司实际上增加了一个额外的轮班来提高产量，并试图跟上需求。但请记住，罗曼，人们并不是真的比平时消耗得更快。他们消耗的方式不同。所以人们在家里使用的卫生纸更多，而不是在工作或餐厅。但这并不是整体上更多的卫生纸。这只是卫生纸去向的分配发生了变化。
And that's the change that suppliers, like roses, are currently adjusting to. So eventually, the supply should catch up to the demand. And in the meantime, hopefully you have enough rolls to get you through. Hopefully, yep, or you have to get creative. You know, even Gibson, who is, I will remind you, an actual toilet paper salesman was willing to admit that, like, you know, when it comes down to it, toilet paper is not that essential. If you had to take society down to like its survival level, we can live without it, but we don't want to live without it. And so we're seeing the stockpiling so that they can sort of check that off of their mental list of concerns and move on to the next
这就是像玫瑰公司这样的供应商目前正在调整的变化。所以最终，供应应该会赶上需求。在此期间，希望你有足够的卷筒来度过难关。希望如此，是的，或者你必须发挥创造力。你知道，即使是吉布森，我提醒你，他是一个真正的卫生纸推销员，也愿意承认，你知道，归根结底，卫生纸并不是那么必不可少。如果你必须把社会降到生存水平，我们可以没有它，但我们不想没有它。所以我们看到囤积现象，这样他们就可以在心理清单上勾掉这个担忧，然后继续下一个
one if it's something they can go out and buy. So when I was outside of the factory interviewing people, I actually did ask everyone that I talked to in line what their backup plan was in case they ran out of toilet paper. And obviously a lot of people were just like, no, not going there. That's not possible. I will not run out of toilet paper. But a few people had actually thought about it and had some interesting answers, including Brittany Pide out, the woman who I told you about who had her daughter pee out of the door of the car. She told me that as a kid, her family actually used newspaper. You know, we grew up a little poor with like great grandma and we'd stop
如果这是他们可以出去买的东西。所以当我在工厂外采访人们时，我确实问了所有排队的人，如果卫生纸用完了，他们的备用计划是什么。显然很多人只是说，不，别提那个。那是不可能的。我不会用完卫生纸的。但有几个人确实考虑过这个问题，并给出了一些有趣的答案，包括布列塔尼·佩雷亚，就是我告诉你的那个让女儿在车门边小便的女士。她告诉我，小时候，她的家人实际上用报纸。你知道，我们小时候有点穷，和曾祖母住在一起，我们会用报纸
it up in newspapers and... Oh wait, tell me more about that. That is that word. Just get the newspaper and you know, ruffle it up a little bit to make it soft. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah. And then that's how we used to back when I was little. That is a good tip, although I should stress here that you should not flush newspapers down the toilet.
把它揉皱，然后……哦等等，多告诉我一些关于那个的事。那个词。只要拿报纸，你知道，把它揉皱一点让它变软。哦是的，是的，是的。然后这就是我小时候用的方法。这是一个好建议，尽管我应该在这里强调，你不应该把报纸冲进厕所。
But if you want to support local journalism and have a backup clean system all at the same time, you know, subscribe to the paper. Yes, all for supporting your local newspaper. The other thing a lot of people said is that they just use water if they ran out of toilet paper, which, surprise, is actually how most of the world cleans themselves after going to the bathroom. 70% of the world doesn't use toilet paper,
但如果你想支持当地新闻业，同时又有一个备用的清洁系统，你知道，订阅报纸吧。是的，全力支持你的当地报纸。另一件很多人说的事情是，如果卫生纸用完了，他们就用水，这，惊喜，实际上是世界上大多数人在上完厕所后清洁自己的方式。世界上70%的人不使用卫生纸，
and most of those people just use water. In some places, they use bidais, in most of the Muslim world, people clean themselves with water in their left hand. And I think that sounds maybe to some people, like it's unsanitary, but let me remind you that toilet paper sounds really gross to a lot of the rest of the world. Like you're just kind of smushing things around down there, not actually getting clean. And you know, a few studies have actually shown
而这些人中的大多数只是用水。在某些地方，他们使用坐浴盆，在大多数穆斯林世界，人们用左手用水清洁自己。我认为这在某些人听起来可能是不卫生的，但让我提醒你，卫生纸在世界其他大部分地区听起来真的很恶心。就像你在下面把东西抹来抹去，并没有真正洗干净。而且你知道，一些研究实际上表明
that toilet paper does it very little to stop germs from getting onto your skin. So, like, not actually more sanitary. Not to mention that I'm sure you remember the original claim that made toilet papers so popular that it prevents damage to your delicate regions. That is just not true. Toilet paper actually can make hemorrhoids worse.
卫生纸在阻止细菌进入你的皮肤方面几乎没有什么作用。所以，并不是真的更卫生。更不用说我相信你还记得最初让卫生纸如此流行的说法，即它能防止对你娇嫩部位的伤害。那根本不是真的。卫生纸实际上会让痔疮恶化。
Doctors are not true. The toilet paper actually can make hemorrhids worse. Doctors are not fans. Yeah, I had a friend who had some surgery down in those areas and he always washed himself thoroughly with soap and water rather than using paper because it was so sensitive. And he needed to get it more clean. And he said this thing and it always stuck with me is that if you got feces on your hand
医生们并不赞同。是的，我有一个朋友在那些部位做过手术，他总是用肥皂和水彻底清洗自己，而不是用纸，因为它太敏感了。他需要把它洗得更干净。他说了一件事，一直印在我的脑海里，那就是如果你的手上沾了粪便，
You wouldn't use a piece of paper to clean it off you would clean it off with soap and water. I mean, that's what I'm saying It's not good in design. It's just good marketing. It's just good marketing. That's exactly right. Yeah Of course, you know bad design can be comforting and especially in these times if it makes you feel better Go out and buy your toilet paper. But if you can't find any, then maybe consider joining your friend and the rest of the world in using water, and then you can wash your hands. Which is another thing we should all be doing a lot more of.
你不会用一张纸把它擦掉，你会用肥皂和水把它洗掉。我的意思是，这就是我想说的。这不是好的设计。这只是好的营销。这只是好的营销。完全正确。是的。当然，你知道，糟糕的设计也可以是令人安慰的，特别是在这些时候，如果它让你感觉更好，那就去买你的卫生纸吧。但如果你找不到任何卫生纸，那么也许可以考虑加入你的朋友和世界其他地方的行列，使用水，然后你可以洗手。这也是我们所有人都应该多做的一件事。
Everyone, keep washing your hands. Well, thank you so much, Stephanie. This was really great. I learned a lot. You're welcome Yes, sir that is thirty five dollars All right, so how to forty you have five dollars change here. Did you receive? So I can drive up this way give it to the sponsor gentleman over there will get you loaded, make sure to stay in your vehicle for me, sir.
大家，继续洗手。好吧，非常感谢你，斯蒂芬妮。这真的很棒。我学到了很多。不客气。是的，先生，那是三十五美元。好的，四十美元，这是找你的五美元。你收到了吗？所以我可以开车往这边走，把它交给那边的赞助人先生，他会帮你装车，请务必留在车里，先生。
Thank you. Thank you. When we come back, Avery Trollfoman has a very important message from the East Bay Municipal Utility District, and I'm guessing all other wastewater public utilities around the world as well, about what you should not flush down your toilet.
谢谢。谢谢。当我们回来时，艾弗里·特鲁夫曼将带来一条来自东湾市政公用事业区的重要信息，我猜世界上所有其他废水公共事业部门也是如此，关于你不应该把什么东西冲进厕所。
After this, here is a reach-offman. After its journey, from a tree to a factory to a store to your closet to your bathroom into the basin, toilet paper flushes into your private sewer lateral, and that wastewater goes to a public sewer line, to a facility where it gets cleaned. The first part is collection and we screen it. We take out all of the big pieces. So, you know, sometimes we find boots.
之后，这是艾弗里·特鲁夫曼。在它从树到工厂到商店到你的壁橱到你的浴室到盆地的旅程之后，卫生纸冲进了你的私人下水道支管，废水进入了公共下水道，到达了一个被清洁的设施。第一部分是收集，我们进行筛选。我们取出所有的大块物体。所以，你知道，有时我们会发现靴子。
Sometimes we find animal carcass. Did you say boots? Yeah, like a boot, like a foot boot. Nelsea Rodriguez is a public information representative with East Bay Municipal Utility District, also known as East Bay Mud. East Bay Mud provides fresh water from way up in the Sierra Nevada foothills, and then after that water is not so fresh, they gather it up again. And we treat it. We disinfect it, we take out bacteria and virus, we clean it so that it's safe to be able to release it to the San Francisco Bay. They run it through what they call digesters. There are 11 of them on the plant.
有时我们会发现动物尸体。你说靴子？是的，像靴子，像脚穿的靴子。内尔西·罗德里格斯是东湾市政公用事业区（也称为东湾泥浆）的公共信息代表。东湾泥浆从内华达山脉山麓提供淡水，然后在水不再那么新鲜后，他们再次收集它。我们处理它。我们消毒它，我们去除细菌和病毒，我们清洁它，以便可以安全地排放到旧金山湾。他们通过他们所谓的消化器运行它。工厂里有11个。
There are these circular, massive basins that are just constantly churning. You put the wastewater into this digester and then we put a microbe in there and the microbe speed off of the bacteria in there. So they're getting plump and they're then producing methane gas, which we convert and use that gas to help run the plants. I went on a tour of this facility once. It is as awesome as it is disgusting. I mean, it smells like sewage, but the machinery is objectively extraordinary. This machinery is big and expensive. And so when we have issues of something that shouldn't be
它们是巨大的圆形盆地，一直在搅动。你把废水放进这个消化器，然后我们放入微生物，微生物以其中的细菌为食。所以它们变得丰满，然后产生甲烷气体，我们转换并利用这种气体来帮助运行工厂。我曾经参观过这个设施。它既令人敬畏又令人恶心。我的意思是，它闻起来像污水，但机械装置客观上是非凡的。这些机械装置又大又贵。所以当我们遇到不应该出现在废水系统中的东西并撞击我们的过滤器时，它可能会让过滤器暂时停止服务，直到我们不得不更换它。而这只是我们真正浪费掉的钱。这就是为什么他们过滤掉自行车轮胎、靴子和其他大物体的原因。但这也是东湾泥浆希望你
in the wastewater system coming up and slamming into our filters, it can take a filter out of service for a while while we have to replace it. And that's just money that we're really just throwing down the drain. Which is why they filter out bike tires and boots and other big objects. But it is also why East Bay Mud would like you
使用卫生纸的原因。因为它在水中几乎瞬间分解。纸巾则不然，湿巾更甚。即使是那些说它们可以冲走的湿巾？是的，特别是那些说它们可以冲走的湿巾。这是一个广告活动，这是一个不真实的营销方案。
to use toilet paper. Because it's been, it breaks down almost instantaneously with in water. Paper towel, not so much, even less with a wipe. Even the wipes that say that they're flushable? Yes, especially the wipes that say they're flushable. It's an advertising campaign, it's a marketing scheme that is not true.
不要让当地公用事业部门的任何人开始谈论所谓的“可冲走湿巾”。那些湿巾，当它们被冲走时，它们会聚集在一起，因为它们在水中漂浮，然后它们开始聚集成团，它们可以创造出巨大的，我们在行业内称之为“火鸡”。因为它们看起来像火鸡。它们是巨大的恶心湿巾团，直接撞击我们的过滤器，它们对机械装置的破坏性很大。自从居家令发布以来，当卫生纸需求突然增加时，
Do not get anyone at your local utility started about quote-unquote flushable wipes. Those wipes, when they are flushed, they collect because they're kind of floating in water, and then they all start to bunch together, and they can create these huge, we call them in the industry, we call them turkeys. Because they look like turkeys. They're these huge globs of gross wipes that just slam into our filters and they can be really disruptive to the machinery. Since the shelter in place order when there was a sudden demand for toilet paper
内尔西说他们看到废水里出现了更多的湿巾。我们真的在请求公众，请不要冲走那些东西。但如果你没有卫生纸，你该怎么办？你最好的下一个选择是什么？面巾纸还算凑合，它们仍然不是首选，它们不像卫生纸那么薄。这可能是最后的手段，但你知道一块布，一块真正的织物布，用肥皂和水，跳进淋浴间，我们真的在请求这些方法。你当然可以使用湿巾，但把它们扔进垃圾桶，而不是扔进厕所。我的意思是，这就是你说的泥浆无论如何都会对它们做的事情。我们无论如何都会把那个东西扔进垃圾桶。所以你可以节省，你可以帮助我们节省公共废水费率，公共资金，通过不破坏
Nelsie says they've seen a lot more wipes show up in the waste water. We're really asking the public to please do not flush those things. But if you don't have access to toilet paper, what do you do? What's your next best option? Stacial tissues are decent enough, they're still not preferred, they're not as thin as toilet paper. It may be a last resort, but you know a cloth, a actual fabric cloth with soap and water, jumping in the shower, we're really asking for those kinds of things. You can use the wipes, for sure use the wipes, but throw them in the trash, not in a toilet. I mean, that's what you say mud is going to do to them anyway. We just toss that thing in the garbage anyway. So you can save, you can help us save public wastewater rates, public money by not breaking
我们的系统来处理这些湿巾。内尔西是东湾泥浆公司能够在家工作的员工之一。东湾泥浆正在搁置他们的一些主要项目，但他们不能搁置所有事情。我们当然不能停止处理水。我们不能停止修理破损的管道。所以我很好奇。上次我去商店时，
our system with these wipes. NLC is one of the East Bay mud employees who's able to work from home. And East Bay mud is putting some of their major projects on hold, but they can't put everything on hold. We certainly can't stop the treating water. We can't stop fixing pipes that are broken. So I was curious. Last time I went to the store,
我看到人们在买大包卫生纸，也在买加仑的水。我真的不明白为什么，但因为我看到其他人都在买水，我也买了一些。我以为我们都在为某种疯狂的麦克斯反乌托邦未来做准备，在那里水会成为货币，这是一个我不想完全排除的未来。但内尔西说它并不迫在眉睫，至少我们在北加州很幸运。
I saw that people were buying big packs of toilet paper and also buying gallons of water. I didn't really get why, but because I saw everyone else buying water, I bought some too. I assumed we were all bracing for some sort of mad max dystopian future where water would become currency Which is a future. I don't want to rule out completely But Nelsie says it's not imminent at least we're lucky here in northern California
人们感到恐慌是可以理解的，但当涉及到你的水时，没有必要恐慌，因为你的水很好。我们很棒。然而，我们确实，这是一个非常重要的点。我们确实建议每个人都应该有应急用水。只是东湾泥浆无法控制地下发生的事情。管道仍然可能破裂，他们仍然必须来修理它。
It's understandable that people get get panicked But there's no need to when it comes to your water like your water is fine. We're great We do however though to when it comes to your water. Like, your water is fine, we're great. We do, however, though, this is a really important point. We do recommend that everybody should have emergency water. It's just that East Bay mud can't control what happens underground. A pipe could still break, and they would still have to come fix it.
是的，但这可能意味着我们必须关闭你的水，我不知道，四到十二个小时。在这些情况下，你将需要你的应急供水。我们可以通过不冲走湿巾、轮胎、靴子或任何其他不是卫生纸的东西来避免这种情况。你可以冲进厕所的东西只有两样。从你身体里出来的东西和卫生纸。就是这样。这就是公益广告。如果你再也不能吃火鸡了，我很抱歉。
Yes, but it could mean that we have to turn off your water for, I don't know, four to 12 hours. And in those instances, you will meet your emergency water supply. And we can all help avoid this in the first place by not flushing wipes, or tires, or boots, or anything else that's not toilet paper. There are two things you can flush down the toilet. Things that come out of your body and toilet paper. That's it. That's the PSA. Sorry if you can never eat turkey again.
《99%隐形》本周由斯蒂芬妮·乔伊斯和艾弗里·特鲁夫曼制作，乔·罗森伯格编辑。谢雷夫·尤西夫进行混音和技术制作，肖恩·里亚尔配乐。凯蒂·明格尔是我们的高级制作人，库尔特·科尔斯塔德是数字总监。团队的其他成员是埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、德莱尼·霍尔、克里斯·巴鲁贝、薇薇安·莱、索菲亚·克拉茨克，以及我罗曼·马斯。罗恩·布卢默，我们关于后部清洁历史的专家，写了《擦拭》一书，其中充满了我们没能在这集节目中包含的关于厕所文化的有趣细节，我们将在我们的网站上提供链接。我们是旧金山91.7 KLW的一个项目，在美丽的市中心广播街制作。
99% Invisible was produced this week by Stephanie Joyce and Avery Trouffleman, edited by Joe Rosenberg. Mixed in tech production by Sherefusif, music by Sean Rial. Katie Mingle is our senior producer, Kurt Colstad is the digital director. The rest of the team is Emmett Fitzgerald, Delaney Hall, Chris Baroube, Vivian Lay, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Ron Blumer, our expert on the history of Riren cleaning, wrote the book Wipeed, which is full of interesting details about toilet culture that we didn't get to include in this episode, will link to it on our website. We are a project of 91.7KLW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful, downtown,
本周的《99% Invisible》由Stephanie Joyce和Avery Trouffleman制作，Joe Rosenberg编辑。技术制作和混音由Sherefusif完成，音乐由Sean Rial创作。Katie Mingle是我们的高级制作人，Kurt Colstad是数字总监。团队其他成员包括Emmett Fitzgerald、Delaney Hall、Chris Baroube、Vivian Lay、Sophia Klatsker，以及我，Roman Mars。我们关于瑞典清洁历史的专家Ron Blumer撰写了《Wiped》一书，书中包含了许多我们本集未能涵盖的关于厕所文化的有趣细节，我们会在网站上提供链接。我们是旧金山91.7 KLW的一个项目，在美丽的市中心Radio Row制作。
Oakland, California. 99% invisible is a proud member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective For more information, visit www.radiotopia.com for more information. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at RomanMars on the show at 99PI or on Instagram and write it to. But the drive to get you to listen to old episodes and share those episodes with your friends is still on. And the best place to start is at 99pi.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
加利福尼亚州奥克兰。99% Invisible 是 PRX 旗下 RadioTopia 的骄傲成员，这是一个极其独立的集体。欲了解更多信息，请访问 www.radiotopia.com。您可以在 Facebook 上找到该节目并参与讨论。您可以在 Twitter 上通过 @RomanMars 或 @99PI 关注我，也可以在 Instagram 上关注我并给我写信。我们依然致力于让您收听往期节目并与朋友分享。最好的起点是 99pi.org。本集目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。